Although we each have our own set of traits, sometimes
it's useful to think about traits among a population of
individuals. For example, a population is a particular group or
type of people in an area. So although there are
many ways to identify a population, a common metric is
geography, as you can see here, with a map of
the world. Just as people and families share common traits
because they're genetically related and they share a common environment.
Some geographic populations share common traits because, like
families, they're also genetically related and share a common
environment. For example. Here's a map of the
world, divided by countries, showing you the breakdown for
the trait of sex. For our purposes, sex
simply means whether or not you have male or
female reproductive organs. Now, it is true that
it's possible to have both male and female reproductive
parts, and those are called intersex individuals. But for
our purposes we're only going to consider two categories in
the meantime. In our world map here, the redder
a country seems, the more males to females it has
in its population. And the more blue a country
appears, the more females to males you have in that
country. The closer it is to a more neutral
color, white. So a, a lighter blue, a lighter red.
Or a white color, in fact. This means that the male and female ratio is
roughly equal. So what I want you to do is look at the map here and
tell me. Which two geographic regions in the map here have the highest imbalance
of either males or females? Is it Canada, Russia.
China, Saudi Arabia, Australia, or Brazil. Remember, I want
you to pick two geographic regions that have the highest
imbalance of either males or females. Remember to use the
legend over here and look at the map to see
if you can figure out which countries have the highest imbalance.